June 8th 2010 Russell Wilson fourth
round pick to the Colorado Rockies
baseball I'm fired up when the highest
moments of my life every kid's dream to
be drafted by a major league baseball
team June 8th 2010 June 9 2010 the line
goes flat my dad passes away
highest of the high to the lowest of the
low just like that
my dad laying in his deathbed and just
tears running down my face and you know
what I do next you know and my mind
racing memories flashbacks moments early
mornings getting up taking grounders and
throwing speed outs and deep post routes
to my to my brother and my dad to early
morning car rides to a you baseball to
my dad being the third-base coach fast
forward to the championship high of
winning a Super Bowl holding up the
Lombardi Trophy and the emotions and
excitement of it all blue and green
confetti all over the place and knowing
that you just won the Super Bowl - a
year later the pressure of the game and
the ball on the 1-yard line and this is
the chance to win the game and it
doesn't work and however many millions
and millions of people all over the
world watching and having to walk to the
median what do I say next what do i do
what do I think being married at a young
age and just coming out of college and
everything else - you know shortly after
you know marriage not working out and
realizing you know what life happens
life happens life happens to all of us
loss of family members divorce fear pain
depression concerns worries when you
think about being super positive yes I'm
positive by nature but positivity you
know it doesn't always work because when
you're down 16 nothing NFC championship
game and people are like Russ we're not
going to win this game and like you know
it's not a great situation right now
when you you're facing cancer when you
have you know things you have to deal
with or finances and this and that like
how do we deal with it and it's hard to
be positive in the midst of it all and
what I definitely knew was this that
negativity works a hundred percent of
the time negativity was going to get me
nowhere I started saying to myself new
or his mercies every morning new
beginnings new starts and despite
hardship and pain and worries and
wanting to get through it and how do I
do this I started thinking about a car
you know you guy said I Drive a car and
get stick shift and you want to shift to
neutral well you go from first gear to
second gear all the way to fifth well
you got to know how to shift to neutral
and I needed to shift in neutral
immediately before I crashed sitting
there after the Super Bowl I had a
decision to make
well I let this define my career wallet
it defined my
life hell no what I found out was this
the mindset is a skill it can be taught
and learned
I started ten years ago training my mind
with this guy named Trevor Moe had my
mental conditioning coach and he's been
with me for 10 years and we've been best
friends and partners ever since and as
athletes we trained the body we trained
ourselves to be able to run faster and
throw farther and jump higher and do
these different things but why don't we
train our mind what do you want your
life to look like
write it out you know talk about it say
it what's our language what is our
language look like watch these
highlights rustling your earring their
best moments what is that what does that
look like and be that live that sound
like that the best free-throw shooters
they don't worry about the shot they
just missed they they think about this
shot this putt this throw this first
down then I met this kid Milton Wright
19 years old he had cancer three
different times this day when I went to
go see Milton Milton was frustrated well
so I'm done I don't want to do this
anymore it's my time to go and I said
Milton I started telling the story about
my dad and my dad to say son why not you
why not you graduate earlier why not you
play pro football and pro baseball why
not you why not you why not you so said
Milton why not you if you try T cell
therapy and you try this and it doesn't
work you know you won't remember so
Milton got a smile on his face and he
said you know what you're exactly right
yes I do have cancer Russ but I can
either let this kill me not just
physically but I can also let it kill me
emotionally and mentally and I have a
choice right now in the midst of the
problem in the midst of the storm to
decide to overcome
one of the questions I always get asked
about neutral thinking is this does that
mean I don't have any emotion well we
say absolutely not
yeah we have emotions we have real-life
situations we have things to deal with
but what you have to be able to do is is
to stay focused on the moment and and to
to not be super emotional it's ok to
have emotions but don't be emotional
when people look at me they see that on
the highest paid player in the NFL they
see that I have the girl in ceará that I
have the family and this and that but I
still have real-life situations we all
do we all have you know sadness and loss
and depression and worries and fear I
didn't just get here what's the truth
and how do I come through this better
and that's really kind of how my mind
started shifting it was not just on the
on the success of it all or the failure
of it it was it was on the process like
you know what is the next step how do I
do this right here right now you have a
choice to make in life and for me when I
was young and I didn't have much I made
a choice I made a choice that I was
going to believe that great things were
gonna happen that I was gonna have my
mind set right and I was gonna have the
right language and the right things to
think about which helped prepare me for
the day because I'm just human I just
have ability to throw the ball a long
way and run around and make some cool
and fun throws and and make some people
smile but the reality is is that I still
have pressure I still have worries I
still have fears I still have things
that happen you still have loss
positivity it can be dangerous but what
always works is negativity and never
wanted to live in negativity so I stayed
in neutral I kept my my shift in neutral
and so that's where I lived you know
that's where I've been living ever since
[Music]